빌사남의 간다는 세계적인 도시 그리고
제가 좋아하는 마천루들이 모여 있는
뉴욕 맨하튼에 왔습니다
[음악]
저는 뉴욕의 관광 명소인 첼시에 나와
있습니다 어 첼시는 맨해튼 서쪽에
위치하고 있는데 여기가 원래 되게
낙후된 지역이었어요 진짜 범죄율도
되게 심하고 치안이 굉장히 안 좋았던
곳인데 엄청나게 바뀌었습니다 제 옆에
있는 곳이 비스킷 공장이었던 근데
비스킷 공장을 리노베이션해 음식점이라
뭐 이렇게 가게라는 문화 복합 시설로
좀 만들어서 첼시 마켓을 만들었습니다
관광객들이 굉장히 좀 많이 찾는 어
그런 곳인데 여기뿐만 아니라 여기
옆쪽 같은 경우에는 원래 폐철길
이었어요 사용하지 않던 그런 철길을
공원으로 만들어서 보싱 재생 사업을
완벽하게 자한 어 그런 사례를 좀
만들었습니다 그래서 제가 일단 오늘
첫 번째로 첼시 마켓에 들어가서이
낡은 비스키 공장을 어떻게 리노베이션
해서 어떻게 만들었는지 여러분들한테
한번 좀 하나씩 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다
[음악]
가시죠 저 지금 내부에 들어왔 있는데
예전에 그 비스키 공장일 때 모습들을
좀 놔뒀어요 그래서 저 개인적으로
이게 스토리텔링이 되게 중요하다라고
생각하거든요 오늘 사람들이 예전
모습이 어떤 모습인지 알 수 있게
이렇게 좀 사진으로 잘 놔둔 거
같습니다 그리고 여기 보면은 벽돌로
그때 당시 벽돌을 그대로 살려
놨어요네 그래서 지금 좀 약간 거칠긴
하지만 좀 되게 특별한 어 그런
그리고 공장이 원래 이제 좀 친구를
조금 높게 만들잖아요 그래서 지금
여기도 보면 친구가 굉장히 높습니다
체감상 한 6 7m 정도 돼 보이는데
면적이 그렇게 많이 크진 않지만
커보이는 그런 효과가 좀 있는 거
같습니다 그 성수동이 이런 거
많잖아요 심지어 쓰레기통 마아 약간
공장에 있을 법한 쓰레기통으로
[음악]
지금이 채시 마켓 건물은 구글이
매입을 했습니다 구글이 매입해서 여기
사무실도 좀 같이 쓰고 있는데 구글이
2018년도에 약 24억 달러
그러니까 이제 하나로 한 3조 5천억
정도의 매입을 했습니다 상업적인
공간이랑 사무실 좀 같이 쓰고 있는
것으로 알려져 있습니다 그리고 또
한국에서 좀 비슷하게 만들어 놓은
곳이 있는데 부산에 가면은 밀락
마켓이라고 있어요 그래서 그 밀락
마켓도 아마 이제 첼시 마켓을 좀
보면서 좀 그렇게 만들어 놓은
공간인데 거기 이제 보면은 광한
대구가 되게 멋있게 보이거든요 만약에
이제 좀 첼시 마켓 같이 좀 그런게
궁금하다고 하시면은 부산에 있는
밀라도 마켓도 한번 방문해 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 여기 이제
첼시마켓 이쪽이 그 허드슨 강이랑
되게 가깝거든요 근데 허드슨 강이
이런 그 해산물 유통하게 그니까
공급하게 굉장히 좀 좋 지리적으로 좀
괜찮아요 그래서 이쪽 지역이 그
예전부터 좀 이렇게 신선한 해산물을
좀 많이 팔았다고
[음악]
합니다 뉴 첼시 마켓이라고 불리는
피어 5 7이라는 곳도 있어요 그래서
바로 여기서 걸어서 그렇게 멀지 하는
거리에 있습니다 그리고 여기 좀
특징이 뭐냐면 퍼드 승강 바로
앞이에요 그래서 뷰가 굉장히
좋습니다네 그래서 채시 마켓을 오신
분들은 이쪽도 같이 한번 좀 보시면
좋을 거 같아요네 그리고 지금
옆쪽으로 제가 또 좋아하는 곳인데네
리틀 아일랜드라는 약간 틀린 모양의
콘크리트로 만든 곳입니다 그래서 저기
안에 들어가 보시면 이런 공원이나
이런 거를 되게 잘 만들어 놨어요
그리고 옆에 허트 승강도 너무 좋아서
이쪽도 오신 다음에 저기 리틀
아일랜드까지 같이 오시면 너무 좋을
것 같습니다 한번 저기도 살짝
가볼까요네
[음악]
개인적으로 허드 승강을 전 너무
좋아해요네 여기 진짜 제 사랑할
정도로 감탄이 절로납니다 그래서 저도
만약에 주거지를 선택한다고 하면 허드
강변으로 좀 선택을 할 거 같아요
그래서 그만큼 되게 좀 쾌적하고 진짜
딱 보기만 해도 마음이 뻥뚫리는 그런
공간이 나왔습니다
지금 매각된 사례가 아까 제가
말씀드렸던게 그 원 하이라인이라는
고급 주택입니다 그래서 저기
펜트하우스가 약 한 4,600만
달러에 매각이 됐어요 그래서 하나로
치면은 한 610억 정도 됩니다
굉장히 좀 놀라운 가격의 매각이
되는데 일단 건물이 약간 이렇게
비틀려 있습니다 디자인에 신경을 좀
많이 쓴 거 같아요 그래서 이것뿐만
아니라 지금 옆에 있는 건물들도 다
이제 최고급 주거 시설이 좀 들어와
있습니다 여기 인근이 이렇게 하이
라인이나 이런 지금 뭐 p 57이 뭐
채시 마켓이나 이렇게 좀 주변이
개발되면서 이런 고급 주택들이 굉장히
좀 많이 들어왔다는 걸 좀 확인해 볼
수 있습니다 그리고 저쪽으로 그
정문구 회장님이 또 분양받으신 사례가
또 있거든요 이제 맨하튼에서 서쪽
지역이 좀 이렇게 개발되고 있다
이렇게 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
그래서 한번 좀 하이 라인으로가
가지고 좀 걸으면서 한번 좀 제가
자세히 보여 드리도록 하겠습니다
가시죠
[음악]
그래서 지금 하이라인을 지금 도착했고
이제 여기 보면은 안내판이 있는데
2.3km 나 됩니다 그래서 굉장히
길어요 한번 좀 올라가서 어느 정도
긴지 한번 좀 보도록
[음악]
하시죠 하이 라인에 올라왔는데
올라오자마자 너무 조경이 잘 돼
있어요 그래서 마치 숲에 들어온듯한
그런 느낌을 좀 주고 있는데 원래
여기 가 그 철도가 다니던 어 그런
공간이었습니다 그래서 그거를 살려서
이렇게 공원으로 좀 만든 어 곳이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요네 그래서 원래
운송 방식이 철도로 이제 운송을
하다가 이게 트럭으로 좀 바뀌면서
여기가 폐철길 이였어요네 폐철
길이였는데 이거를 공원으로 좀
만들면서 도시 재생 사업의 진짜
어떻게 보면 대표적인 사례라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 그래서 아까
말씀드렸던 원 하이라인 어 여기
팬트하우스 사례를 말씀드렸는데 거기
앞에 있죠 바로
그래서 여기도 진입하기에 되게 좋게
돼 있고 그 지금 저기랑 저기도 다
이제 급 두어 시설로 되
있습니다 진짜 뉴욕 시민뿐만 아니라
관광객들한테 굉장히 좀 사랑받는 어
그런 곳인 거 같아요 그리고 여기를
보면서 좀 다른 나라들 이게 좀
영감을 많이 준 거 같아요 우리
나라로
치자면 그 서울역의 그 고가다리
아시죠 차도 굉장히 많이 빌리고 좀
유관상 좋지 않았는데 어 거기도
이거를 좀 따라서 어 이렇게 공원으로
좀 만들어 놨습니다 그래서 저도
실제로 가봤는데 어 생각보다 되게 잘
만들어 놨더라고요 처음에 여기를
개발한다고 했을 때 여기를 다 철거한
다음에 하려고 했었어요 근데 이제
여기 주변에
주민분들이 되게 반대가 좀 심했습니다
그래서 지금 철기를 좀 최대한 살려
달라라고 해가지고 지금에 철기를 좀
살리고 좀 공원으로 만드는 방식으로
좀 변경이 됐다고 합니다 그래서
어떻게 보면 지금 봤을 때는 굉장히
좀 잘한
[음악]
선택이었죠 그래서 저희가 하이라인을
걷다가 어 배슬 그지 왔습니다 배틀은
올라가지 못해요 여기 안전상의 이후로
어 올라가지는 못합니다 일단은 제가
오늘 하이라인 걷고 첼시 마켓도
들려서 느낀 점은 뭐냐면 개발되지
못했던 그런 낡은 공장과 그리고 이제
폐철길 이렇게 좀 도시 재생 사업을
함으로 인해서 여기 인근이 이렇게
바뀔 수 있다라는 걸 좀 느낄 수
있었습니다 그래서 이게 좀 공원으로
바뀌고 그다음에 첼시 마켓 문화 복합
시설로 바뀌면서 여기 인근이 진짜
완전 많이 좀 바뀌었고 좀 이렇게
부동산 가치도 좀 많이 올라가는 걸
좀 보면서 우리나라도 뭔가 이제 좀
이런 낙후된 지역 이런 곳들을 무조건
철거에서 그 신축을 하는게 아니라
기존의 그 폐철길 이라든지 공장이라
그 모습을 좀 최대한 살려서 이렇게
도시 재생사업 하는 것도 괜찮다라고
좀 많이 느끼게 되었습니다 좀 우리
나라에도 잘 보존하면 괜찮을 만한
지역들 있잖아요 어 기존 모습을 좀
유지한 채 이렇게 좀 개발한다면 진짜
하이라인이나 최시 마켓처럼 좀 그렇게
관광 명소가 되지 않을까네 그렇게 좀
생각을 합니다 그리고 좀 추천을
드리자면 배스를 좀 보고 여기 엣지에
전망대가 되게 멋있거든요 그
전망대까지 본 다음에 여기 하이라인을
건서 첼시 마이 아니면 57 그다음에
리틀 아일랜드까지 보시면은 딱 좋은
관광지 않을까 생각이 듭니다 그리고
첼시가 원래 이제 택의 공장이 근데
그거를 개발한 사례가 또 있는데
거기가 바로 브루클린 이니다 그래서
좀 브루클린 한번 좀 보면서 거기도
좀 어떻게 개발이 됐는지 촬영하도록
하겠습니다 기대하셔도 좋습니다
[음악]
and I'm so
sick but to Que with
you I